you work with a good friend of mine mr.
Tracy Morgan on the lassithi what's it
like working with Tracy as he as you
know he first of all we're all glad that
he's well that he he survived his trials
and tribulations but he is an amazing
character he is he is a crazy fun
character I love doing that show the
last og and then you know I went to see
Tracy you know after he got well and got
the Walmart money yeah so he he bought
this big huge mansion and I went with my
agent and it was the one of these first
times I ever saw like white privilege
kick in because my agent just knocked on
his door and opened the door and went
the house and I'm like do black people
have dogs or something Tracy was very
living you know very rich he had the
robe on he can the long cigarette a
small dog in his hand I was like but he
hadn't got all the rich stuff down right
you know so that night we got caviar on
Ritz crackers you know like champagne
reported in kool-aid cups you don't have
all the real really hot stuff down yeah
a lot of cars a lot of car trees morning
out a lot of cars a lot of sports cars
we would we would ride around the block
he had a Bugatti one day I'm in a
Ferrari and we just get in and ride
around the neighborhood and then he just
parked and that was it it was he takes
him once around the block that's it
we'll switch cars
I was living the life it's doing it I
was like dude this is like somebody just
got money this is like you've been on 30
rock please come here he wasn't getting
Bugatti money